a scary creepy exorcism haunting movie
brought to you by the doors not the
doors to hell or any [ __ ] like that no I
mean like the doors no kidding
[Music]
deliver us from evil to deliver us from
evil is yet another haunting horror
exorcism ghost dish story this one with
a cop investigative detective element to
it Eric Bana plays his copy buses check
he's like oh she's crazy but of course
we all know she's gonna have some demon
possessing her and [ __ ] and there we go
we got more of that going on and its
partner Joel McHale is in this movie I
was like alright you're investigating
and then you get the soup from your
partner that's cool oh my god how many
cliches can you throw into this movie
you got it all now you know when you're
like I've seen it all
trut you have seen it all and a lot of
it is in this movie you got the main cop
he doesn't believe in this sort of [ __ ]
of course because he can't because it's
a movie about this lights that go out of
the most unto moments the flashlights
that go out after the lights go out to
make the really dark moment creepier
sounds in the night the little girl
who's scared in bed scratching sounds
under the floorboards the jump scares go
luckily alright here we are let's
actually go back and read you the title
intro to this video
[Music]
jump-scare fest 2014 yeah that's more
like it
that's what this is jump-scares here
jump-scares there jumpscares everywhere
jump scares my cats jump scares my dogs
jump scares by weird creepy imagery that
has nothing to do with the movie the
most overused one is this weird bloody
face looking guy crawling over bedsheets
or some [ __ ] on the screen for no reason
like what is that the guy is that the
creep we're looking for maybe it is but
as it stands right now in my mind's eye
is completely irrelevant [ __ ] there to
creep out the audience I enjoyed and
actually like the fact they tried to
have this cop investigative element to
it it was almost like this movie he's
trying to throw back to the movie fallen
there are moments you feel like it's
pulling it off you're like oh maybe it's
know it's just more cliched should be
creepy but on creepy [ __ ] and jump
scares coming out of here what this
movie lacked was logic reason and
subtlety then there's a cop priest guy
is like I know what this is I deal with
it all the time you need to come with me
you need to absolve yourself of your
sins he's mean they're tough cops not
going to get you through this smoking
would things gonna learn the lesson
we're gonna take on the bad guy together
you know it you know there's gonna be an
exorcism scene at the end of this movie
and there is I'll give the movie props
though is contradictory this is going to
be - all my information saying this
movie is unoriginal
I will give it props for originality
there's a scene in the exorcism scene I
swear to God the dude stands up you're
like creepy sounds gonna happen and they
kind of do what do I hear break on
through to the other side [ __ ] you not
the doors came on for some weird ass
reason the doors is like some underlying
theme in this movie it's everywhere in
this movie and it's an exorcism saying
maybe laughs I'll say that it may be
like fact is if you like these creepy
ass movies you've seen everything that's
in this movie there's no point for you
to see this movie you'll be bored out of
your mind you'll be like I've seen it
done before and I've seen it done better
than this the movies rated R so here's
what's going to happen a bunch of
teenagers are going to go to the box
office this week and be like Oh we'd
like to see earth to echo please I just
want to say earth to echo they're gonna
sneak into this movie and that's how
it's gonna go down
still more enjoyable than that
Paranormal Activity the marked ones
piece of [ __ ] this movie tried but the
fact is it's one of two things a cliched
paranormal movie with a cop twist to it
or a boring cop movie with a paranormal
twist to it because deliver us from evil
you're not gonna remember it in t-minus
10 minutes you already forgot for the
entire movie I was like who does the bad
guy in this movie remind me of it and
finally I was like holy [ __ ] it's jared
nomak from blade - where's what's the
shittiest
a normal movie you have seen oh yeah
we're going negative on this one
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]